inappropriate welcome to the billion
podcast on you hey you really hit on you
I don't mind that at all welcome back
guys is gonna watch you're sucking your
kisses back I was right a judge Liam
podcasting this you guys feel like it's
been a while
this episode is brought to you by D STL
denim a an awesome Jean company with
really high quality denim Jenna's
wearing a pair right now and if that
doesn't settle you I don't know what
will
d STL denim is a really awesome company
they make really high quality jeans for
affordable prices don't mind the fact
that I have fake tan inside my belly
buttons reminding it mind it reminding
it it minded mind it a hundred percent
sweatshop free and cutting out the
middleman can be really helpful get the
jeans live right to your house prices
starting at $65 really high-quality
awesome comfortable and stylish most
importantly jeans go to DST LD calm I
mean y'all know I love my leggings but
when I put these on Julianne was like
damn girl and I was like I was like damn
these are my jeans like damn is [ __ ]
also this processing is naturebox
which we were talking about is actually
this person that's why we ever had so
get yourself some naturebox delicious
healthy wonderful tasty and guilt-free
snacks you can have delivered right to
your house in this nice nature box box
every month or I think you do like every
two weeks and you get to choose your
snacks you choose which ones your
favorites there's so many options we
chose the spicy sriracha popcorn the
corn Mesa the Mesa crisps and the blue
corn tortilla chips
[ __ ] yeah and I'm really honestly proud
of myself that I've waited this long t I
know I usually they're like empty bags
because you know getting an H of X on I
can't like it all you wanna be like up
now time to inhale
can't even help myself so thank you
response and we like when you guys treat
us your nature box treats yes oh sorry
guys go to nature box hug nature box
common is going to get two free snacks
right now she was all about alright so
we are going to read fanfiction today
well the last time that we did this it
was fan fictions about you and I and we
did like look on there a little bit for
us
yeah I fell down a rabbit hole of
looking up other people and I just
started giggling my dick off so yes
you're doing that hurt like an hour well
what in the first one we didn't want to
read them like we wanted to read them
for the first time on the podcast but
this time I did do a little pre readings
I wanted to make sure that they were
they were working yeah so we compiled a
bunch of different fan fiction stories
about multiple different people not us
and we're gonna read them oh my god are
you ready for this even well you're
looking pretty hard and ready even you
were laughing pretty hard when you were
getting yours ready so I'm excited are
you gonna need some sriracha popcorn for
this I'm gonna try out the Mesa
Christmas like some of these are so
inappropriate and I might not read all
the words okay oh you're just gonna eat
a Mesa crust without me you got it and
some Irish give it to me hmm
moans [ __ ] alright alright you ready
yeah so the first person that I looked
up for fanfiction was Donald Trump you
you I'm trying to find the name in the
upper okay it's called God God it's
really long I don't think we're gonna
read the whole thing or like all of them
I don't think we're gonna read the whole
whatever it's just called Donald Trump's
mutt bye we love you Allie we're smut I
kept seeing that you know what that
means I do
mmm-hmm you know what it means all right
just like dirty dirty [ __ ]
yeah smut isn't an acronym I don't think
so sex monster under table mm-hmm yeah
exactly
all right all right chapter one I was at
Subway ordering a Big Mac when all of a
sudden the sexiest man I had ever seen
came out of the kitchen he had on a
bleached blond
toupee had wrinkly skin stunning blue
eyes and a sexy business suit not to
mention he smelled like a mix of vodka
and chucky cheese just my type hi I'm
Donald the sexy man said with a slight
grin what may I get for you what may you
get for me you could get me that dick of
yours
I pushed Donald on the floor and ripped
off his business suit I'm gonna suck
your chicken so goodly I said I gotta
buttoned his pants to see this is so bad
already to see 69 feet of pure man pop
up I shoved all 69 feet in times like 69
feet Wow thanks I don't want to read
that okay as I was about to blah blah
blah his dick fell off I stared at
Donald Donald astonished baby girl he
said my hair bit may be fake and my dick
may be fake but my love for you is it I
smiled as his love Baba I'd want to read
that I jumped up to hug him but actually
accidentally swallowed it whole I fell
on top of Donald and then died because
the fake date was a to bomb the end then
died oh my god back when we read chapter
1 but there's more you ready wait how is
there more she died no that's right now
I'm like intrigued ok ok chapter 2 I was
sitting in my house trying to log into
my club
I tried again and again and again just
as I was about to give up I felt the tap
on my shoulder hello need some help yes
please daddy Don Donald smart I love it
when you call me I can help you with
that password on one condition
and that is you you let me [ __ ] your
Club Penguin loving ass
I really want to log into my Club
Penguin account and I can't lie dog is
pretty hot deal don't smart deceitful
no no I'm not reading any of that no no
oh my god no you're a brony hell yeah I
am Donald said as he slept
[Music]
Donald's four centimeter penis [ __ ]
you're so big Don I can't this is so
filthy oh okay nope mm-hmm that he
humped my ear once this is filthy
okay nope up done with that Rizzo done
with that one should I read my donovan I
was like seven saviors oh you have a Don
one know the Elijah of the one that
Eliza wrote the day yeah one more little
bit all right you keep going it
I was sitting comfortably in my room
eating carrots and watching television
just as I went to dip my carrot and
ranch Mickey Mouse Clubhouse came on I
knew what I had to do I jumped up
spilling the ranch all over me and sorry
to sing alongs mi ck you IMO USC that's
me as I was singing I felt something on
my leg I looked at it Donald Trump
licking ranch off my thighs hey Big
Daddy I said [ __ ] was Donald [ __ ] he
was so sexy he got up and grabbed the TV
remote now let's turn on something hot
like wiki posting isn't hot enough I
thought to myself
keeps the chance of Peppa Pig [ __ ] how
did he know animated pigs turn me on
he started licking ranch off my stomach
and then said now it's time for the real
show she reached in the pockets of his
short shorts revealing a hamster
his name is striker he got up and took
off all his clothes except its cat and
threw them across
I was about to lick his left titty oh my
god okay then we both see Bob Duncan
entering the room I'm here to
exterminate your virginity sorry Donald
already took that I said well [ __ ] you
then he said he killed Stryker they put
the room with his vagina flaps my
favorite part is licking ranch
okay well then because we did Donald
Trump I also found Hillary Clinton fan
fiction energy did you chapter one I
want to say who this is by it's called
Hillary Times reader by fangirls feld
PHA n like dan and phil fan girl forever
one one two two chapter one the debate
you are the biggest Hillary Clinton
supporter out there you have a weird
crush on her almost like she's your soul
mate deep inside that's ridiculous you
say to yourself and sighs sadly you go
to the debate wearing your Clinton 2016
t-shirt with a sign that said the same
Hillary went on and on about her plans
for America but you couldn't help but
daze off while looking at her gorgeous
blue eyes Hillary looks at you you snap
out of it
hello oh well someone's a big supporter
of mine what's your name hon says
Hillary she's speaking at you at long
last I'm Jenna you say what a beautiful
name you're quite the smart one for
choosing me for your presidential choice
she says the audience laughs later after
the debate she bumps into you hey Jenna
says Hillary she grabs you and pulls you
close to her you're beautiful / handsome
like they're all like you would see your
name in my name
no dude Jenna Jenna okay you're
beautiful she says she leans in for a
kiss
you lean into you both passionately make
out as if you known each other forever
you pull away and realize something
you're married oh my god you're married
I completely forgot
what are you doing kissing me aren't I a
little young for you you scream she
bites her lips and falls food clothes
bill doesn't have to know anything she
says you continue to pass while Donald
Trump walks by he throws up in the
Scream screen
Donald Trump continues walking and
Hillary begins to put her tongue in
she's the best French kisser ever
the kiss is filled with heat and emotion
call me sometime my number is eight
seven six five five five six five six
five she says yeah cool mine is your
number you say chapter two a call
Hillary called you on your cell phone
late at night when you need her love you
were asleep so she leaves you a message
hello its me I was wondering if after
all these days you'd like to get coffee
and maybe Netflix and chill you wake up
the next morning put on your stunning
black and blue outfit and meet Hillary
at Starbucks in your brand-new North
Face and Uggs who dad bought you for
Christmas
she was writing an email using her
personal account it was work-related but
you like a bad girl girl you get a venti
cafe mocha low foam extra whipped cream
and milk with caramel sauce topping with
a triple Chunk chocolate chip cookie you
sit down with Hillary
she says quietly hi I didn't make Isis
oh I know you say romantically soon you
two get swept up with each other and one
thing leads to another and other stuff
happened Hillary was now pregnant with
your child
Chapter three of birth hillary sat in
the birthing room propped up on gold
bars and money she waited four hours and
20 minutes
soon after she began birthing little
humans out popped 21 kids she named them
idk blaze it Fred Bernie Zodiac killer
Trump Pig
leijen jerky Marco cheese it vans Daniel
Starbucks white girl number 16 James
Kelly sushi Turkey and 21 Starbucks was
your favorite child she had a little
Hitler stash like Donald Trump's Cali
James Legion and jerky were all really
mean and stupid so you gave them to top
man's was super pale paler than the
white his fans and Daniel looked
identical geez it was orange like Donald
Trump so you obviously named him after
him
sushi loved the Japanese nurse Turkey
was always sleepy white girl number 16
was even whiter than bands and Daniel's
and loved Starbucks
then you named more after politicians
chapter for home at last you sit there
with your children all 18 of them white
girl number 16 was drinking Starbucks
out of her sippy cup and bands and
Daniel were playing together the
giveaways were being held by you baby
what are you doing those are Donnie's
kids you say what I never said you
trying to make me look like a fool I
never said that you're trying to make me
look like a fool Hilary says well I
don't want them they don't even look
like they can be mine with all those
mustaches you say Hillary sighs and
screams loudly I don't even like women
anymore I want my Billy boo back you
sigh and no that's just your sweet hilly
always inconsistent you go home with
your favorite kids IDK it 21 white girl
number 16 and Vince you spend a few days
with your kids and when your mom and dad
kick you out for getting a girl pregnant
my god you sigh it off and go live at
Donald Trump's abandoned mansion it's so
big you can fit a small loan of a
million dollars in there
Hillary calls you back on your cell
phone while idk is trying to eat white
girl number 16-foot you answer knowing
she'll be begging for your love hello
BAE I love you come back says Hillary I
thought you didn't like women anymore
she said stop saying that you're trying
to make me look like a fool Hillary
exclaims you're Hillary is back in your
loving arms again
more is there more yeah TMZ came dashing
to your door they heard the scandal
Donna was at your front door laughing at
the countless drama magazines lined up
at your door you escaped out the back
with Starbucks white girl number 16 idk
21 Daniel and Cali you really didn't
like Cali that much but they were okay
in the end
Hitler comes up looking for his Trumpy
Phu while holding his four children
Hitler was extremely pregnant and wanted
to his Trumpy back home you turned to
the children you made it out with you
what you find Trump's daughter boy in
the bushes huddled up and scared so you
take boy into your arms and hold her you
take her home in your poor person car so
you don't get spotted by the press you
go home with your kids and give them
makeover so the press doesn't recognize
them you pick up Daniel you dye his hair
blond and renamed him Rolf Jacob
Sartorius and then let your friend
babysit for you when you when press gets
big on the scandal you make it look like
you're not his mom you pick up start
Starbucks of white girl number 16 you
let your friend Barney babysit when
press gets too hot you hold you pick up
Callie and put darker foundation on her
and you send her to your hometown where
she is called ELISA Bella and they're
really really really ugly and mean to be
continued my favorite part is that she
had these 21 kids like in the matter of
like a day yeah got pregnant at birth 21
kids I want to hear more about it good
to please it so after that I decided a
good hole to fall into was Guy Fieri
yeah fan fiction I was a brilliant idea
I thought of it too and then you're like
no I already did there is I think
there's two that I got what I read one
the Donald one sir no you want to move
on why don't we save Elijah's fur I
always save this for less sure laughter
right right this is called girl Fieri a
Guy Fieri tale by Kaylee the loser the
beginning it was the Summer of o.9 and I
saw my dream men staring at my burger
from across the bar he approached me
still looking down at my burger that's a
good-looking burger Bert
milady he said licking his plump lips I
felt my ovaries explode
what a gentleman you can have it if you
want I said I wasn't hungry after seeing
what a large sausage I'd be eating today
I've watched him shove the entire burger
in his mouth
smooth rice I've never seen such beauty
in my life are there other things you
eat like that
I asked hinting at the sex I was
undressing him with my eyes and was
excited for the rippling 84 pack that he
was making under his sexy button of the
blame shirt well I do like pizza he said
obviously not understanding my reference
to eating my warm food AJ I had to admit
at first it seemed like he was only
interested in my food but I knew in my
heart that he was truly interested in me
and not just my $40 vegan cheeseburger
after you finish my burger he looked up
at me I couldn't see his eyes through
his $1.00 kitty sucks but I'm sure his
I'm sure his eyes were sparkling like
diamonds he reached up to my ear and
pushed my skinny blonde dreadlocks
behind my gauged ears he made me feel so
warm inside like a fresh croissant
alright
I like your earholes he whispered
sensually I like your [ __ ] I said
things are starting to get spicy and I
loved every moment of it I wanted his
flamey body chapter 2 why am I still
writing this so do you like frozen yes
obviously referring to I like how it
started the Civil War of Norway same he
said while twirling a piece of his hair
with his finger in a flirting fashion
who was then that he leaned into me and
whispered do you want to go to
flavortown I was startled sure but I'll
have to ask my mom first you can call
her on my blackberry he said with great
flavor
and you calling my mom would be a
problem I hadn't seen her in 20 years
and I heard she was managing big-name
celebrities like Nash Grier and Jacob
Sartorius where he quickly shadowed over
me like a cumulus cloud I knew that I
had to ask my mom's permission to go to
flavortown but where is she got a blast
I said running out the door of the
subway shop suddenly stopped I was under
his spell I looked back a guy to see him
he had frozen time please don't leave me
flavortown is so dull so dull without
someone share it with it's hard to
explain I know I love you but I just
have to leave please I just need
something to remember you by
I looked at him sadly inside as I ripped
out one of my ear gauges and I also need
$40 for your cheeseburger I fished for a
400 dollar bill out of my nest of hair
and threw it at him forget flavortown
sweaty he said next time I see you
you're going to flavors shitty so
accurate that rude sweatshirt from
flavor town once guy released me from
his spell I couldn't stop thinking about
him I just needed to find my mom so I
could go on the trip to flavor city with
my guy I needed to find my mom quickly
so I wouldn't keep the guy waiting all I
knew about my mom is that she manages
Jacob Sartor clitoris I would start
there I quickly got out of my Barbie
laptop and researched Jacob it would be
easy to find my mom through him I being
searched
Jacob Santa Claus Jacob Santa Claus and
was amazed by the beauty of his creature
Maui Wowi I said staring into the face
of God I snapped out of it quickly
remembering my dedication to guy of her
journey to flavor City I quickly found
his phone number thanks to Instagram
user Jacob start Tori 5 lover 69 and
gave him a call hey babe Jacob answered
I need my mom I said I was wondering if
guy was monitoring my calls and thought
I was cheating on him
hey des check out my new hot single
sweatshirt now on iTunes for only a
dollar 29
I knew this was a sign Jacob would never
be that fake to me I suddenly remembered
all the superspy strategies that the
Pink Panther had taught me I decided to
try some of them out on Jacobs new
single sweatshirt I played it backwards
forwards and upside down nothing finally
I decided to decode the lyrics I found
exactly what I was looking for I think
you need something of me Jacob knew that
I was looking for my mom the only
question was would he help me the
secrets of Jacob Sartorius I knew in my
heart that I had a connection with Jacob
but I had to talk to him in order to
reach flavortown with guy I was in it
was flavor city I was in a play for town
flavor city I sure was in a pickle I
suddenly heard my walkie-talkie go off I
hoped it was guy it wasn't it was Jacob
I picked up my walkie-talkie
hey this is Jacob check out my new
single sweatshirt available on iTunes
and Spotify
cut the crap Jake up you know it's me
Zappa t yes Jacob it's me can I talk to
my mom please yeah she's right here
sucking me off Jacob I need to go to
flavor City and you're the only one that
can help me please fine she left to go
out to get a Brazilian wax at Walmart
about how her go but if you leave now
you might be able to catch her bye Jacob
bye love I couldn't believe what I just
heard Jacob loves me I put that aside it
didn't matter I'm devoted to guy and no
smoking hot nine-year-old will ever
changed oh we're gone I decided to focus
on finding my mom maybe she had some
advice to give me about my love triangle
I drove my dolphin shaped car to the
nearest Walmart I walked in and saw her
instantly waxing her vajayjay in front
of guy hoppity's mom mom I said with
sorrow and my dark orange eyes saw
zappity I can except suddenly and was
interrupted by guy wait your name is
zappity what the [ __ ] man that's crazy I
once had a hipster dick softening I
guess we were just a match made in
heaven I said looking into his small
rat-like eyes with passion in love
sweaty why haven't been answering my
calls guy said oh god I said
remembered where my phone was I had
thrown it in I had thrown it Charles the
Starbucks barista when he told me that
sapa tea was a weird name I'm sorry
Charles if that's even your real name
but of course I couldn't tell that to
guy he'd kill me he loves baristas
almost almost as much as he loves his
left earlobe Janice I quickly made this
story
I'm so sorry guy I've just been so busy
because I'm pregnant and it's yours I
felt my voice start to tremble
I just hope guy is dumb enough to buy it
what's a pregnant guy said my mom got up
and ran at the speed of a dab out of the
sliding doors at Wal Mart mom no I
screamed turning towards the door I
watched her as she stole my dolphin car
and drove off stopping only to flirt
stopping only to flirt with the guy with
the other dolphin car I felt my heart
snap and - I could never go to
flavortown without her permission and
all I wanted to do was go to flavortown
with the love of my life my mother my
fake baby's grandmother gone I was
terrified I slid onto the ground and
began to cry ketchup tears then suddenly
I felt the warmth above me beaming onto
my skin like a ray of Sun it was guy he
took off his Katy glasses and put on his
aviators he looked more beautiful than
I've ever imagined I know losing your
mom is hard
I dropped my ice cream on the ground
once he said I suddenly stopped crying
I finally found somebody who truly
understands me and all the pain that I
go through
he had just cured everything inside me
except my sweatshirt fever I didn't know
if anything could cure my love for him I
couldn't even say his name in my head
without feeling butterflies in my
kidneys I shook my head and remembered
my true goal in life to get to
flavortown with guy I felt the light
fading away from me I mean that's pretty
late I was captivated there's a bunch
more chapters it keeps going for a while
keeps going for a while I just wonder if
she got the flavor city I don't [ __ ]
know man but I imagine she has to say
well-written I love that people take the
time to write stuff like that
it's a beautiful contribution to the
world it was really beautiful
speaking of flavor city guys get
yourself some big
my nature box has an awesome selection
of sweet savory treats and snacks
delivered right to your door guys you
don't have to go anywhere they're
shipped nice and tidy to you in a
beautiful package and you can try
different things or keep the same stuff
every month you can change your
subscription the style of a often bought
box has come the frequency of snacks and
every idea but I'm telling you like
these snacks are very very good they
don't taste like you should be eating
them but they're good and they're mm-hmm
they're delicious they have we're
Jenna's vegan I'm gluten free so there's
so many different options for people I
got chips with black seeds flax seed so
listen guys flax seeds they have over a
hundred delicious snacks to choose from
you guys can get two box or two for
snacks right now for free if you go to
Gen Y naturebox.com/tyler Julian and for
those of you who have tried it you know
exactly what what they have theirs I'll
read you some of the different snacks we
have like five right here but there's
big island pineapples a really good one
crispy coconut squares they have like
really savory ones like teriyaki beef
jerky or teriyaki turkey jerky roasted
kennel kernels dark chocolate they have
like everything so check it out guys
instead of eating cookies and junk get
yourself some nature box and avoid the
guilt
naturebox.com/tyler children to get your
first two snacks for free and you see
what the hypes about other sponsor this
week is d STL denim this awesome company
ships jeans right to your door stylish
once you know your jean size guys you
don't have to do any work you don't go
shopping and spend all this time in a
store with people you don't want to be
around you just just do that you have
people do the work for you
they have fashion for designs and a high
moral fiber guys they stripped it down
to the essentials quality denim and
good-looking jeans for you so check it
out by going to DST LD comm see their
selection like if you want some jeans if
you need some jeans they
we spend a ton of money on reading the
expensive jeans get yourself some GST LD
because it's high quality and you're not
paying out the ass that's what you got
to do low cost awesome fashion check it
out
I mean Jenna's cute little bottom speaks
for itself right now because these look
awesome and I have a pair too I'm just
too hot to wear them right now because
I'm always hot I'd also just like to say
about a lot of times I don't have like
the longest legs in the world but a lot
of times when I buy like skinny jeans
like this they're like way way way too
long at the bottom because they're built
for crazy tall people which I'm not and
these are probably one of the only pairs
of jeans that aren't like way too long
for my legs you don't have to like get
tailored or just bunch up and yeah for
sure and like like you'll find a style
that works for you there are different
styles so once you find a style that you
like you just you know exactly what you
need
prices start as low as $65 per preparing
very cute pretty cute yeah nice
are you jealous I am I want to come on
in Oh jealous of my jeans thank you to
our sponsors um so I was thinking I
should jump in now or you could read
this one the cook of my dream it's
another guy fieri are you going reduce
that gap gonna read my Zeca phone
alright get eggs
it's called I'm ready I'm here for this
all right
it is called Zach I frankly was like how
do I see the title this all about how
exact a front is my oops like this
boyfriend or sorry husband Zac Efron is
my husband oh sorry bye girl of many
fandoms 7 ready you guys ready mm-hmm
this is lit okay you and Zach are waking
up confused as hell you don't know sorry
no that's the second chapter here we go
you Zach why are you looking at me like
that
Zach it's just you're so beautiful I
can't take my eyes off you you oh you're
the sweetest guy Zach I tried for my
beautiful girl my place you what
want to do their Zach just watch the
movies and invite people you okay keep
in mind you're 18 and he's 20 and hot
and he's also single Zach if you want it
it could just be us I said yeah I'd like
that
Zach's house you want to watch Annabel
me yeah but I'm scared of horror movies
Zach it's okay I'll be with you yeah I
like that
later you screaming Zach get it away
I like it once you're scared oh my god
you're mean no I'm not I'm just hot yeah
I can see that Zach looks into your eyes
and leans in to kiss you you closes your
eyes and gives in Zach you're so
beautiful and I love you you Zach you
are the best boyfriend Zach you're the
best boy Zach thinking one day I'm gonna
marry this one that's was I thinking
Zach yes or no you're the best
girlfriend and in three to four years
you're gonna get something pretty you Oh
what is it
Zach you'll see oh wait what time is it
Zach it's like 1:30 can I just sleep
here
yeah you can sleep in my bed okay that's
fine 3:05 a.m. hey I can't sleep Zach me
either what do you want to do you I
don't know I'm just poured Zach kisses
your forehead I love it when I'm by you
you make my world and I mean it I love
you yes or no why do they keep doing yes
or no that's your name Oh your name I
love you okay Julian Julian Zach if we
were married how many children we would
have Zach ten imprints the in
parentheses thousand you know no no no
no I heard that
Zach well that's a dream crusher you
okay only six that's my max Zach okay I
can work with that 10:00 a.m. I got I
gotta go to work I love you hon Zach I
have to shoot a new movie I'll see you
tonight I love you too babe one year
later you both get married and act like
party animals you both are at work in
the next chapter it's a surprise you're
going to hate me for it but oh well deal
with it there will be secret by the way
from okay here we go chapter two the
night test you and Zach are waking up
confused as hell you still don't know
what happened two weeks ago and you're
pissed at you that you don't remember
one thing from that night
Zach also doesn't remember [ __ ] or that
much [ __ ] you what we do at the party I
remember us coming home after we had
tons of sex but did we get drunk oh my
god I know we were we were having so
much fun though I had eight joints of
weed and you had ten kinky liquor shots
kinky lived I guess we were [ __ ] up
last night it's a measurement eight
joints of weed you holy [ __ ] did you
wear a [ __ ] condom Zach yeah I did
you
burps continuously I gotta go go do what
you run to the bathroom and pukes all
over Zach baby you okay you Zach why
would I be okay Zach damn don't be
snotty you shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
Zach while you scream and fuss I'm going
to take me and my [ __ ] to work
literally grabs whole ass and leaves
[ __ ] I'm going to the Sam pharmacy store
to get a test [ __ ] bastard at the
Soraa I got this damn thing now I can go
[ __ ] bastard mystery voice hey Julian
you who said that it's me Dave Dave
Banco I think they meant Franco you oh
hey Dave Dave what are you up to you I'm
getting a present pregnancy test for a
friend oh is that her calling you oh
yeah hey what's up Emily I got your test
for you for when you and Justin didn't
use one okay bye BRB Dave all right I'll
take that to that that's Emily I'll see
I'll take that too Emily I'll see you
later ask for a hug yeah I'll see you
around hug him back register lady $10
please
what the [ __ ] $10 for two goddamn tests
they better come with Mari does that
mean no idea at home you I better I
better hurry he gets off in two hours
[ __ ] I forgot about dinner you go
upstairs and wait five minutes you
nervously looked down the test you
starts crying a river no I can't have a
baby now Zach walks in the door pissed
hey baby you what's wrong and what
happened at work why are you here early
they they [ __ ] replace me and what's
behind your back you nothing I'll tell
you later just go lay down and blow off
some steam okay I love you
me too baby screaming on the inside how
can I tell him later you go up to Zack
and ask him all what happened and
finally tell him that you apologize
about being a [ __ ] Zack I'm sorry about
being a [ __ ] I have to tell you
something Zack what is it the thing
behind your back yeah that was a
pregnancy test I'm pregnant
Zack what I always wanted to be a dad
wait you're happy Zack maybe I kind of
lied when I said I put on a condom I
wanted a baby I just didn't want to tell
you good Oh baby I love you is that
felony to rub your stomach and I also
love you Zack you're going to be good
parent we're gonna be good parents right
kisses cheek and puts your head on his
shoulder Zack yeah we are kisses for
head and stomach check on your due date
app and you're doing Zack hope you like
part two I can keep going
yeah okay I'm in Chapter three man
period Zack is acting like a prick since
the two of you found out you were
pregnant Akash to you for nothing
hey Bay Zack hey bait you yeah Zack when
the [ __ ] you gonna learn to do dishes
right you baby please not today why do
you always want to pick a fight Zack
[ __ ] off you are you having a man period
because you're pretty [ __ ] right now
Zack I'm going to Dave's house to clear
my mind you by clear your mind you mean
get someone else pregnant or smoke weed
Zack baby why are you bitching lately
slams bedroom door behind behind him in
your face I want to talk to you you baby
please I love you Zack calms down and
starts tearing up scratchy voice baby I
love you too you calm scratchy voice
with teary eyes can you let me yet
please Zack opens door with red eyes
tears rolling down baby I'm sorry I'm an
[ __ ]
I just I sighs I thought I could handle
a child but I'm just a failure you hugs
him baby everyone thinks through it
everyone everybody thinks they're ready
if it's okay if you're not I wasn't
either when I found out but I was happy
when I didn't know it baby everything
will work out I love you no matter what
even if we're the worst parents in
history I'll still love you
Zak baby I hate myself for being a dick
I love you so much
maybe one of the miscarriages or you die
it miscarriages yeah you baby this is so
many days baby that's that's something
for the future to take care of right
right now let's let's do the best of the
present let's go see a movie okay Zak
okay Zak speedo V I can't believe actor
like a dick to Julian I'm killing myself
I'm an [ __ ] I hate the person I am I
just feel like a dick but he doesn't
know I cheated on him when I said I went
to Dave's hassle you Zak what's wrong
Zak I think we should go you but it's
almost over Zak we need to go okay fine
we're going [ __ ] at home I had to go
baby I'm sorry I'm going to take a
shower
puts phone on table okay watches you go
upstairs wait till shower goes on waits
two minutes picks up sex phone Zach's
texting your girl saying I love what we
did that night my wife would never would
never have done that with me while she's
pregnant that's me
oh my god the messages Zak baby that was
the best thing ever
Vanessa oh oh oh my god you were so
great Zak I missed that once we broke up
after high school musical
so is that happening it may be when I go
to Dave's house Vanessa I gotta go I
gotta go Dave's here Zak by Vanessa I'll
be waiting for eight equal sign equal
sign equal sign capital D your POV he's
cheating me what the [ __ ] find this
relationship has done that [ __ ] I was
I was played a dirty trick wait till I
get my revenge you hear footsteps and
quickly put down his phone and run out
the door slamming it you get in car and
tears boiled down your eyes and you
suddenly think to yourself [ __ ] I left
his phone you go to Dave's house and you
don't see Vanessa Scott his wife you
walked to his door knock Dave opens it
sees you cried quickly hugs you and
holds you close and says what's wrong
you showed the messages and he gets mad
and calls his soon-to-be ex-wife
he turns red of anger and tells her
they're through he runs to you kisses
you on the mouth dave tells you to kiss
to take him to your house of beats
access you open the door and Zach looks
pissed he grabs you by the arm before he
put before you in pulls Dave in and
punches him
face sends you to get some clothes and
stuff from your house and replace it
with Vanessa's Wow
that's the end of the chat fish we keep
on my goodness
the nicer is called revenge if you want
I did we get it you can hmm what are you
thinking about on the house baby that's
pretty [ __ ] wet like what a twist
that was what a twist
wow what a rush all right all right I
like that this is called Harry are we
comfortable in here
Guy Fieri and the Fieri in my heart by
jiggly jello Joe all in my heart chapter
one the cook of my dream this there's
parts of this that I cannot read okay
since the first episode I had been in
love with Guy Fieri
I had my room decorated with sheets and
wallpaper of him I even had four body
pillows of him two of them were well
used all capital letters well use I had
a corner full of stuffed figures of him
I even bought a bag of a few hairs of
his that fell into his food that
restaurants owner saved they're already
gone though I put them in my food and
ate them once I do my business I pluck
the hairs out to rescue the hairs for my
nest next meal that is disgusting is hot
back in my old high school I made a club
about him I was the only member I was
never lonely though I kept two of my
body pillows the unused ones one for
each arm I talked to them and covered
them in my saliva when no one was
looking it was an after-school ritual I
always had dreams about him welcome to
flavortown he'd say as I sank to my
knees desperately clawing at his flavor
stick it always ended before it got good
unfortunately I love him I'd let him
drip salsa on me and eat it off with
chips I'd let him preach ooh my food for
me I want him just stuff my expletive
like he stuffs a quadruple patty burger
and even with all the ferocity he does a
steak I'd let him do anything to me I
had graduated high school last year and
now I was working in a restaurant my
dream is to open my own restaurant and
have him come in and review my food and
then my expletive is the P word yeah
peewee so naturally when I heard he'd be
coming to the restaurant I worked out
for his show I was ecstatic words
couldn't describe the feelings that I
felt that day when I had felt feelings
that had been felt that day I had
feelings to be felt just remembering
makes me giddy
April 23rd that's when he showed up I
woke up at 1:00 a.m. to spruce myself up
for the occasion I couldn't stop
thinking about it the owner of the
restaurant had told me I'd be the one
cooking his meal I this would have been
the perfect opportunity to lace it with
Viagra or roofies of course I couldn't
because of the cameras and he'd be
watching me ladies with Viagra
Guy Fieri watching me cook my body was
already trembling with pleasure
I felt okay nope not reading any of that
nope okay finally the moment came I
heard the bustle outside the kitchen I
peeked out to see a camera crew running
about I walked to the window and peered
outside into the warm spring day the Sun
was bright sending a wave of light down
onto the ground as if an angel was
descending the heavens submerged in that
light was an angel my angel guy drove
his red convertible out of the bright
light his shades glistening with
sunlight his bleached hair flowing
through the wind elegantly like wind
blowing through leaves his bowling shirt
flailed around wildly a thrashing Beast
worn around his body I couldn't be any
okay oh my god it says my my I couldn't
be any letter my P word was overflowing
people were slipping on the floor I
didn't care I quickly checked my
reflection in the window would I be good
enough for him I could only hope I stood
by the owner awaiting
Finley's arrival of guy I stood my hands
clenching my apron my heart was beating
like a drum but it felt so right the
nervousness had a feeling of belonging
he bursted through the door shouting
loud in his sexy voice welcome to
flavortown his voice makes my body
quiver and don't the smell of expensive
overpriced cologne filled the room I
couldn't stop sniffing there was a hint
of hair gel swirling in the Cologne he
looked at the owner putting an arm
around him looking into the camera I'm
here in Orange County with Todd Baker
where his famous deep friends southern
stuff wrapped and dope deep-fried then
stuff again monster burger burrito
Philly cheesesteak sandwich on a pizza
is made hearing guys say the owner's
name and seeing his armor own and was
enough to make me want to kill my boss
out of jealousy the owner said something
about the restaurant I honestly wasn't
listening my eyes were glued to his
beard and all the excess grease and
crumbs in it Oh what I wouldn't give to
suck them out of his dear dog finally he
looked at me and said loud and this is
Nikki Frost ugh she will be cooking for
me this wonderful meal today he didn't
even have to touch me and I expletive
expletive expletive yes well let's take
a look inside the kitchen guy said
gesturing for the camera to look at the
back of the room PAS did what a dead guy
looked at me he gave me a smirk almost
cynical almost excited do you see what
this says freeze right here oh my god it
is so graphic that's a lot
it is so graphic it's good though you
want to read some sure read some Julie
I'm so here for this Guy Fieri fan
fiction
getting heated in the kitchen on camera
we went from station to station
explaining my the purpose of each and
every one my eyes were glued to guy
however I even chopped off one of my
fingers but it was all okay once we get
in the bedroom I'll have him use it to
[ __ ] me my god maybe even heaven put it
between a hot dog bun okay that's it
made me shudder in pure pleasure at the
mere thought that came to my part I
begin cooking in front of him I could
hear him talk taking a loud sniffing
letting out a satisfied gas behind me
but something weird was going on he kept
leaning closer to me sniffing leaning
closer
sniffing and caused my hand to
erratically shake he stood by the
manager smells good right but you can't
wait to eat it the manager was Tooting
his own horn as guy nodded oh yes I see
something I really want to eat his eyes
gravitated to my ass I can feel his eyes
on my ass I first he licked his lips
getting saliva stuck in his goatee and
in mustache I wanted to turn around whip
off my shirt spread flour all over my
body
God rotten penis is on my body with his
tongue
I wondered if he'd let me call him sauce
daddy hopefully he will as I worked on
the meal I made sure to drop every
[ __ ] thing in the kitchen and bend
down moaning and wiggling my booty as I
picked up I figured giving him an
appetizer to the for meal will ignite
his passion the fumes filled the room
with sweet delicious scents of food it
was the perfect romantic setting food us
tables and chairs in a restaurant
several cameras pointing us kinky dirty
thoughts raced through my mind his
actions his voice in his words I
couldn't believe it it seemed like he
was hitting on me I was overjoyed even
if it wasn't true I let out an
ear-piercing squeak for the record time
of 1 minute and 55 seconds taking a
breath after that spectrum my manager
and the character looks
everyone did except guy who kept looking
at me smiling licking his already wet
lips finally the food was done after
making his usual commentary on the
preparation it was time to serve it to
God we walked past the best table we had
and he sat down I came out carrying the
food I was envious of the food I'm ready
to eat me out like this food I sent him
the steaming plate in front of him and
his eyes remained fixated on me on my
breasts i wheeled running behind the
camera crew unable to control myself
what was i doing my one and only love
was staring at me and I ran stupid
stupid stupid guy went on with the show
and violently dug into his food
destroying it wrapping his tongue around
each part as he jammed it his tongue in
the each milking cranny
his saliva dripped down into the food
the fluid soaking into the food I
couldn't stop watching I swear had an
erection watching this he devoured the
food stuffing into the meal stuffing the
meal into his mouth the meat into his
mouth cramming it deep and down rubbing
his tongue all over I was practically
mowing behind the camera crew who were
trying to kick me away out of fear I
couldn't handle it it was too good there
is a I can't say that quack quack I
moaned while splashing after a few
minutes he finally finished his food he
made his commentary on it it was over
the heaven I was living it only lasted a
few hours he had all the footage E&M was
now going I wanted to die I felt like as
if I'd received part of myself that had
been missing for so many years and now I
was leaving if Guy Fieri came by one by
one hugging each employee and when it
was my turn I screamed and backup to see
a wet trail coursing down his shirt I
realized I did that and blushed
profusely happy that this part of me
would stay with him forever the camera
who loaded up and we're ready to leave
we were going outside to watch him leave
but then something happened he hopped
out of his car walking up to me sorry to
ask this but I left my sunglasses in the
kitchen can you come with me to unlock
the door so I could get them his sweet
incident innocent smile made my heart
pound and I nodded we walked into the
kitchen and when we were inside he
closed the door I was too busy obsessing
over him to realize we don't lock our
kitchen doors
so good should we move on here you just
swipe up sausage swallowing oh my god am
i doing a good job reading it yes you
going Sasha's falling I turned to him my
eyes filled with confusion and
unexpected fear he smiled his smile
pushed his cheeks up until they almost
covered his eyes so starting to tricky
like this I didn't know how to get you
alone either way he walked towards me
out of instinct I backed up until I was
pressed against the wall his belly
rubbed up and down my body a belly dance
from guy I couldn't contain my juices I
see you're already wet imma juice you
out like an orange and I'll drink you up
he said as his tongue slithered around
his mouth and he made a slurping noise
oh oh my he's gonna make me into an icky
milkshake I thought to myself without
warning his lips met with mine and a
moment of blissful peace despite how
fast my heart was beating I felt calm is
calm and safe as I could be I'd rate you
a 5 out of 5 on taste appearance and
preparation he rated me I don't deserve
this heaven without warning I was thrown
into my knees he looked up I looked up
at him with my eyes wavering sir I
stammered he smiled down at me he
reached in his pants and his hand came
out covered in cheeto dust [ __ ] done I
rubbed it on my lips I'm going to make
you my [ __ ] now kiss me [ __ ] I want
that cheeto dust to my mouth compliance
command to stand up meeting my lips with
his Joyce with a joyful reunion his
tongue slathered around my lips all
traces of cheeto were erased and sucked
the black void of it and sucked into the
black void of his mouth salvia or saliva
mixed together into one giant ocean of
love him I was his sausage [ __ ] I sang
to my knees and untucked his flame
covered bowling shirt oh my god passion
I ripped his flaming bowling shirt off
him only find another one I'm not with
his ripped jeans and let him drop the
floor finally all my dreams are being
achieved I reached into his boxers and
pulled out his mega doodle noodle I was
taking okay
my producers were probably wondering
where we were but I did not care he
wrapped a hand around the back of my
head and looked straight in my eyes in a
deep voice of the seductive under 20
said welcome to flavortown ok I'm not
reading the next paragraph it felt so
right I look up in his eyes I couldn't
tell if I'm the look on his face if I
was doing it right but that was all that
mattered I couldn't control my body
around him I would do anything anything
to see him pleased I managed to
stabilize myself stabilize myself by
pushing off his thighs ok ok ok I'm
gonna give a little bit here this is so
good it's crazy graphic I'm scared we
have to move to the next chapter
scroll up I did target uh it happened
hmm she let out a mighty roar that
stumped the Trump trying triumphed over
Shrek's on own mighty bellow and woke
the children on the other side of the
world it was a magical moment 3 2 1 got
a blast
damn oh god no what I like start a
sentence and I see where the sentence
goes if I can't finish it mmm ok when I
awake I was I was covered in many
different things
salsa potato apparently she passed out I
saw some potato chips crumbs taco shells
roast beef as if someone had eaten over
top my body upon looking around I
realized I was home my heart began to
sink I was in my bed at home I passed
out in the restaurant unless it was a
dream I sniffles and try to hold back
tears my eyes flooded however in streams
of salty droplets rain from my eyes then
from the abyss my heart was sinking into
let's make sense though the smell cheap
cologne hair gel and grease the water
was running in the shower like a lion
locked onto its prey I dove into my bed
I dove off my bed sprinted into the
bathroom swung open the the door my eyes
widen in disbelief he was actually here
in my room Guy Fieri he put on his flame
bowling shirt he took a shower in my
room I made sure to lick every drop of
water out of the shower later
now I was however I was drooling in
delight I slipped my tiny I slipped my
slimy saliva and looked at his beard he
looked up from the man eyelet taxon but
his shirt and with a big smile
Nicky sweetheart how are you after that
crazy ride to flavortown I was afraid
you were dead he but he burped each word
it's nothing of pickles and pepperoni
wait wait so we really matched meats I
quietly guess there is no dream it was a
reality
mashed meats Nikki we pulverized our
privates God he laughed aloud causing my
face to tint of pink he kneeled down on
one leg and smiled up at me from his
back pocket he produced the half Ian
onion ring in hand and handed it to me
Nikki will you marry me as he smiled I
could see a bits of spinach in his teeth
it didn't stop me from tearing a weird
rush of emotion came over me I choked
under my own weight my arms trembled as
I tried to hold them on my mouth my
salty tears slid down my face over my
hands and dropped on to the time onto
the floor with overwhelming enthusiasm I
nodded my head his grin grew even bigger
and he ate the ring after that it's been
six long years every day of every year
was spent in flavortown we have eight
kids know each named after my hubby's
favourite food it's just my Fieri in me
but sometimes when and when I'm feeling
naughty I have an affair with my body
pose well done Wow well done that is
just some ease if you guys want right
anyone wants to read the parts that we
did not say again it's called Guy Fieri
in the Fieri in my heart by jiggly
jell-o Joel don't [ __ ] graphic oh my
god that was so I was so incredible
right should we finish with one more
what do you think yeah I wanted to see
which ones I had left I'm turning it
back to my library
come in one second because we want to
watch Triple D read Elijah's right I
wanted to read this one I only read like
the first paragraph of it and I was so
here for it let's do it and I just
realized that for sure that's Donald
Trump's yeah so this this is called
forbidden love yes are you ready or no
this is chapter one it's called this
ain't my first rodeo by Gucci goldfish
chapter one forbidden love chapter one
is called forbidden love it was just a
normal day at dr. Phil's studio when his
life changed forever dr. Phil was on
stage sitting with his cute petite feet
dangling down now let's welcome Trent
dr. Phil said with no enthuse whatsoever
when Trent walked on stage dr. Phil felt
the connection with him immediately he
was attracted to his darling smile
perfect hair and killer eyes dr. Phil
felt his face get red and looked away
quickly sup Trent said while smirking at
dr. Phil although there was a live
audience they felt like they were the
only two people so Trent I've heard you
made a naughty boy dr. Phil subtly
winked at the teenager forgetting that
they had a 48 year age difference 40
yeah I guess you can say that Trent
returned dr. Phil's flirtatious gesture
making the entire room uncomfortable
especially Robin who was watching with
utter disgust just as dr. Phil was
reaching over to touch Trent Robin
jumped up and shut the show down Robin
took dr. Phil by the arm and yanked him
out of his seat I'll see you later dr.
Phil carefully mouth to Trent Trent
blushed and hopped out of his seat he
couldn't wait to see the man of his
dreams later apparently dr. Phil
couldn't wait either because 15 minutes
later he came back with a box of
chocolate a ring and 60 the 1693 roses
Chapter two somebody call 9-1-1
Trent's ID when he noticed dr. Phil come
in with the myriad of presence what are
you doing
Trent exclaimed running over to hug the
tired and very sweaty doctor I presence
love you dr. Phil fell into a heap on
the floor
Trent immediately freaking out shaking
his lover in hopes of bringing him back
to consciousness after standing in shock
for a few minutes a very upset Trent
called 9-1-1 and got an ambulance to
pick dr. Phil up Trent stayed by dr.
Phil side the whole night although
unconscious Trent knew dr. Phil could
sense he was in the presence of the one
who loved him most midnight Robyn came
to visit dr. Phil then when he when she
saw Trent she became very annoyed uh
what are you doing because this is my
husband last time I checked not yours
Robyn shoved her wedding ring brag Ely
in the teenage boys face almost as if
dr. Phil knew he had to protect his
lover he woke up it said no hesitation
Robyn I want a divorce you nasty toe oh
my god chapter three the doctor has a
surprise what for him Robyn pointed to
the teenage boy who was lit up with
excitement dr. Phil opened his mouth to
reply but Robyn left before he could
answer
Trent sat on dr. Phil's Hospital mm-hmm
and rubbed his mostly bald head dr. Phil
sobbed quietly while Trent tried to
comfort him I want to try something
Trent said he leaned over and closed his
eyes about to kiss dr. Phil's luscious
lips just as their lips we're about to
come in contact the nurse came in the
room you can leave now she said
pretending as if she didn't see what has
just happened dr. Phil and Trent left
the hospital together I really want to
give him smooches dr. Phil mumbled
quietly to himself suddenly the wise
doctor had a wonderful idea I'm gonna
take you somewhere special dr. Phil
winked at Trent who was treading
alongside his forbidden lover dr. Phil
hopped on his brave pink motorcycle and
Trent got behind him clutching on to dr.
Phil's petite with
just like his feet this room 666 oh my
god where are we going Trent shouted
over the loud roar of the motorcycle dr.
Phil ignored his questions continued
after an hour dr. Phil stopped at a
dingy hotel dingy hotel in the middle of
nowhere we're here cowboy
let's go dr. Phil slapped Trent's butt
and led him inside the sketchy building
dr. Phil went to the front desk and rang
the bell sitting on the counter yo Pam
its dr. P I want my usual room dr. Phil
smirked at Trent who is blushing and his
face was full of confusion where are we
Trent was starting to get worried it's
okay babe I do this all the time dr.
Phil squeezed Trent's cheek a few
moments later a few months of
uncomfortable silence Pam came to the
desk and gave dr. Phil his key have fun
you two
Pam winked and strutted away dr. Phil
took Trent's hand and led him into their
hotel room room number 666 my girl's
dirty secret dr. Phil unlocked the door
and led Trent inside the inside of the
room had a very dark and gloomy feeling
Trent do you know who I am dr. Phil
glared at the wide-eyed teenager and
smirked Trent suddenly became clammy and
pale uh-uh
Trent almost lost consciousness when dr.
Phil carried him to the bed and laid him
down gently I'm saying dr. Phil okay and
you are my sex slave strapped is called
gay produces Trump there Trent jumped
off the bed and shrieked man I may be
gay but I'm not gay for Satan Trent
pulled the cross out of his pocket and
threw it may the power of Jesus be with
you Trent screamed and Satan suddenly
burst into a ball of flames
the end
who knew that all the fanfiction is like
that it's so funny so funny these people
are funny dr. Phil said with no
enthusiasm whatsoever what sir all right
so when we finished with Elijah's yeah I
have one that we didn't get to but we'll
begin a new car - it's lovely
yeah whatever our friend Elijah wrote
this awesome
Donald Trump fanfiction that actually
got like recognized from news outlets
like it blew up he was invited on talk
shows and stuff it has 250 mm reads on
Wattpad and it's more than that that's
just what pad it has like 500 ratings on
Amazon with almost a five-star rating
like it's so yeah so I'm going to read
some will read all of it this is called
the billionaire and the bellboy chapter
one mysterious meeting it all started
one fateful afternoon in the summer of
2012 I was working as a bellboy at the
Trump Hotel in Hong Kong on an
internship program it was marvelous I
come from a very small farm town of
Michigan and this is my first time in a
big city I loved everything about it it
was all I could have ever dreamed of in
more but little did I know it was all
about to change I'm stacking someone's
tacky luggage when the door behind me
swept up and my loins trembled at the
CENTAC toupee adhesive and spray tan as
it swept through my nasal cavity I
wanted nothing more than turn around and
see a golden God behind these scents but
I couldn't move I was frozen there was a
tap on my shoulder young man the voice
said I thought to myself oh God could
this be him there was only one way to be
sure I gathered all my strength and
turned around was i hallucinating this
couldn't be real it was him it was
Donald he stood there in front of me
like like a tall stallion with his oily
orange skin glistening in the sunlight
as if it were a soggy cheeto his hair
unkempt and messy like a gorgeous rat's
nest he is beautiful more beautiful than
I could have ever dreamed yes sir I said
nervously I need you to bring these up
to my room he said sternly like a
grandfather upset that a news broadcast
interrupted jeopardy
his voice wrapped around my body like a
queso oh no sorry like queso around a
smothered burrito that's better I was
unable to speak what does this feel like
I'm having I'm forced I forced myself to
speak but only one word what would come
out I don't have all [ __ ] day you
loser I'm so sorry sir i whimpered s I
grabbed his bags I'll get these up to
you immediately
he should get his head and trotted off
towards the elevator as he got further
and further my eyes continue to be Glu's
dick glued to his rear end his gorgeous
ass flaps behind him like a
mouth-watering stack of pancakes and his
pants my hunger for pancakes have never
been stronger my god and that's when it
happened
he looked back and caught me staring at
his donk he could've had me immediately
fired for this but he didn't instead he
smiled and continued to hop on the
elevator what is happening am I losing
my mind I didn't come here to find love
but I did the but did love find me no I
couldn't be I ran to the bathroom and
splash cold water on my face this is
insane I must be crazy I said to myself
in the mirror as the cold water dripped
down my face in uniform I stood there
for minutes just looking into my
reflection I gathered myself dry it off
went to the front desk I need a break I
demanded from hell in the hotel manager
that's fine be back in 15 she growled at
me
I hope 15 minutes is long enough for me
to figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
I almost I was almost out the door
before the phone rang Helen stopped me
wait she yelled as she hung up the phone
take those bags up to mr. Trump's room
before you go on break he needs them now
and he I specifically that you bring
them he did what he has specifically for
me to bring them why me so many
questions racing through my mind like a
cool teenager teenager on he leads in
the mall I got it mr. Trump's luggage
and headed for his elevator his luggage
said made in China on it how ironic my
harpy was faster than the elevator as a
ticked upward I wonder why he asked for
me what could this be about I wonder if
he likes me how could this just how
could he just like me he just met me
ding that Lybia ring as we reached his
penthouse I walked down the hall to his
door I walked this hall many times but
never before has it seemed so long it
felt like an eternity I wipe the sweat
from my forehead and put the
and up to his daughter or not he
answered the door wearing only a robe
the robe open enough just for me to see
his beautiful saggy chest a chest that
would give Betty way a run for her money
finally I've been waiting he complained
as he took his bags and slammed his door
my heart saying I guess he just wanted
his bags as soon as I began to pick up
the pieces of my shattered heart the
door whipped open again I almost forgot
he said and handed me a wad of his money
as a tip as a piece of paper and a piece
of tip paper
don't be late he said and he said with a
smile as he closed the door once more I
stood there paralyzed holding what it
looked like hundreds of dollars in this
note what was the note I pulled it from
the money and held it up the note said
be back here at a p.m. and get yourself
something nice to wear my knees trembled
as I read it I could this couldn't be
happening but it was I told Helen I
wasn't feeling well I left work early I
couldn't be there anymore I needed to go
home oh my god
keep going chapter 2 blood sausage you
know I walked through downtown kicking
uh thinking about everything
I can't even thinking about everything
should I go back to meet him at 8:00
p.m. no I can't do that what am I
thinking
I'm not I'm thinking about him I
couldn't find any more I had to admit I
wanted his geriatric 2006 Perez Hilton
jello body and I wanted it bad but
before long we had a new problem my
lustful thoughts had awoken the
purple-headed yogurts linger in my pants
this walk was getting real hard real
fast
I need to get home look yet luckily I
live right around the corner I opened
the door and quickly jogged up the
stairs making sure no one saw the
bulging blood Sasha's out so I was
sausage I was rocking I sat down on the
couch and before I could even take a
breath my roommate Nicole open the door
and came out what's up you fat [ __ ] she
said not a whole lot I lied I had to I
couldn't tell her why are you acting so
[ __ ] weird she's she asked I'm not I
said I've met a boy is he cute she said
I asked as she asked how she made a
sandwich gorgeous his face is wrinkled
like a beautiful overflowing flesh
toilet I said daydreaming what the [ __ ]
does that mean that's really weird
nobody [ __ ] talks like that she said
he's
was a rich I followed okay go get that
dick boo she said I gazed at the clock
6:00 p.m. already having gone shopping
yet I rushed them all I need to get an
outfit and get home in time to change I
quickly found a perfect black suit and
it was on my way home I googled him on
the train home I wanted to know
everything about him his Wikipedia page
says he's 69 years young what a magical
number I'd like to find out more about
that it also said that his nickname is
the Donald but I'm pretty sure they mean
daddy I was so excited for her meeting I
couldn't believe this was happening
I got changed looked at myself in the
mirror you can do this I repeated in my
reflection I got myself pretty and
headed up chapter 3 the meeting oh sorry
ok so the number I said earlier was just
the chapter 1 stats the walk there was
short that's what yeah I thought I had
over a million yeah I think it is but I
felt like an attorney I was so nervous
for our second meeting never in my
wildest dreams could I imagine this
happening I reached the building and
made my way up the elevator my heart and
meat monster both throbbing more and
more with each floor we passed the hell
of a ring route and opened doors like a
white girl's legs on prom night I forced
myself to walk down the hall my legs
were heavy fighting me against every
step I looked at my phone 750 APM just
in time I'm not gently on the penthouse
door the door creaked open there he was
handsome as ever like a giant melting
fat carrot with fake hair he was wearing
a gorgeous suit you look good he said as
I entered the room he locked the door
behind me and asked if I wanted to take
a seat why did you ask me here I asked
as I sat down you know I asked you here
he said as he brushed his hand against
my cheek leaving a stream of self-tanner
dripping down me
he sat beside me and put his hand on my
thigh caressing me up and down the only
thing I knew was that I wanted to ride
the elevator to the top of his Trump
Tower he have enough clothes you're
putting his cold dead lips on my neck I
shivered with excitement his hands felt
like an old dried-out gingerbread house
I was in love I should tell you
something he breathed onto my neck tell
me later I said as I reached for his
pants fine close your eyes he said I was
reluctant and obedient i unzipped his
pants
touch his cold scaly thighs open my eyes
on
his thick long tail what Donald Trump is
a [ __ ] reptilian I screamed and let
go of his tail his neck flared up like a
dinosaur on Jurassic Park you know which
one I mean he pissed and left for the
window leaving nothing behind but broken
glass and shattered hearts I guess we
just read the whole thing well we did
yeah oh whoops chapter four I bet you
didn't [ __ ] expect that oh yeah and
then it says thanks for reading I'm so
sorry for like Trump temptations
remember to follow me on Twitter
comm slash a guy with no life which we
recommend a guy with no legs is
incredible he is awesome he's constantly
like doing epic trolling - everyone
always hell yeah oh I was incredible
that was a really fun one Elijah it was
unbelievable he's quite the wordsmith I
must say he is it's good good writing
this is my picture the guy he runs for
me though those were just that one was
so graphic the one thing you can do is
skip over all those parts it's like it's
so a lot of control
alright well thank you guys for watching
this podcast if you want us to read more
fanfiction in the future and like have
ideas of who we should look fanfiction
above that would help and we can
definitely do more fun as [ __ ] I didn't
realize how fun it would be to read but
you random ass fanfiction cuz it's goofy
and vibe or funny people is funny dumb
um guys check out our sponsors
description below as always and thank
you so much for hanging out with us
we'll see you learn it so we've got
another podcast thank them love you guys
Fabio